[Musique]
beaucoup de personnes en voyant cette
belle assemblée
on y voit des citoyens des consommateurs
à convaincre ou des militants engagés
dans un nouveau projet et ben nous à la
boîte à champignons ce qu'on voit ici
c'est du co2 de la chaleur dégagée par
tous ces corps de l'humidité et on peut
pas s'empêcher de penser que ce serait
super intéressant de connecter la
climatisation de cette salle a une sale
d'agriculture urbaine qui seraient
revalorisés ce co2 cette énergie et
cette humidité
on vit on est en train de passer une
transition et si vous êtes là parce que
ça vous intéresse
vers l'industrie de la revalorisation
on sait déjà depuis longtemps recycler
le verre on sait récupérer l'énergie du
freinage d'une voiture on s'est même
transformé des tripes de poissons en
gélules d'oméga 3 qu'on va vouloir très
très cher en réalité en faisant ça on ne
fait que poursuivre le chemin qu'on
préparait pour nous nos ancêtres parce
que pendant très longtemps nos ancêtres
ont été les formidables réutilisateurs
en fait une notion assez moderne
c'est une notion qui est lié à l'ombre
dans ce qui est lié à la société post
seconde guerre mondiale que créer de
l'abondance et comme marqueur de
l'abondance qu'est-ce qu'on a généré le
déchet et il ya tellement de personnes
qui sont battus pour ça que finalement
c'est un état de fait
et bien moi ce que je vous propose et
c'est qu'au lieu de s'emmitoufler dans
ses déchets c'est d'essayer de se
réconcilier avec eux si on cherche un
modèle qui marche depuis de nombreuses
années
qui connaît l'abondance mais qui ne
connaît pas le déchet et ben y'en a
plein et le premier il a 80 km d'ici
s'appelle la forêt de rambouillet la
forêt de rambouillet au mètre carré
produits beaucoup plus d'unité productif
que le meilleur des chambres et de
bosses ça s'appelle une prairie ça
s'appelle une lisière ça s'appelle un
lac
tous ces endroits là sont des
écosystèmes où tout se nourrit de tout
où on a un certain nombre d'organismes
qui savent retransformer quelque chose
et qui crée de l'abondance sans créer de
déchets une fois qu'on s'est dit ça on
est content mais on sait pas trop quoi
en faire je suis d'accord avec vous
ce qu'on cherche à faire à la boîte à
sion pignon en fait c'est d'avoir le
même regard sur la ville que ce qu'on
pourrait avoir sur une forêt et comment
on fait ça on va chercher méthodiquement
à se dire ok moi on est en ile de france
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme ressource
abondamment disponibles en ile-de-france
à une première ressource dont personne
ne veut c'est justement le déchet et
notamment le déchets organiques
donc qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a cherché
d utilisation intéressante et on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 600 mille tonnes
de marc de café sous le pied de 3 kg de
restes de bière un peu de cartons un peu
de bois on en a des quantités colossales
et nous ce qu'on en a fait c'est qu'on
l'a transformé en substrat de pleurotes
et pour consultables pour l'europe parce
que avec le marc de café on obtient la
rolls de la pelote et cette rolls de
pleurotes elle vient ce succès à quoi
des girolles qui viennent de parfois on
sait pas où elle vient se substituer à
la viande
elle vient se substituer à tout un tas
de choses à des gélules de compléments
alimentaires
parce qu'elles sont hyper scène et donc
on va créer à partir d'un résidu hyper
hamon dans un produit qui va répondre à
tout un tas de solutions
le problème en tout cas l'opportunité
c'est qu'il ya pas que ça comme
ressource amendement disponible dans une
ville qu'on le veuille ou non les
problèmes d'insertion et l'exclusion
sociale sont inhérentes à la ville et
dont ce qu'on s'est dit c'est que pour
que ça marche pour être le plus utile
possible
il fallait qu'on adapte notre process
notre savoir faire industriel à
d'insertion et c'est ce qu'on a fait et
on a travaillé pendant longtemps avec
ares et aujourd'hui on a sur quatorze
personnes dans l'équipe
une autre quatorze personnes qui sont
des entreprises d'insertion qui
travaillent avec nous au quotidien pour
transformer notre substrat et ça nous
permet aussi d'aller en italie se
développer avec des entreprises
d'insertion italienne ou en belgique
allait se développer avec des
entreprises d'insertion belge troisième
ressource abondamment disponibles celles
qu'on n'a pas trop envie de voir mais
qui nous casse les pieds c'est la friche
la friche urbaine et on s'est dit ce
serait quand même top de réussir à se
mettre dans les friches urbaines et de
revaloriser des lieux dont plus personne
ne veut
donc on a commencé par des conteneurs
frigorifiques on a transformé des
conteneurs frigorifiques en mini
champignonnière ensuite on est allé
s'installer sur le grand marché de
rungis vous avez plein de
bananière des systèmes de mûrisserie de
bananes sont complètement obsolète qui
sont l'ennemi à l'abandon et ben les a
transformés en cave de champignons et
plus récemment on à reconfigurer un
grand site horticole qui ascendant la
bretèche parce que l'horticulture en
france s'effondre et on à reconfigurer
ce site progressivement ensuite
d'agriculture urbaine
on a un autre problème dans notre métier
c'est pour faire 2 kg de pleurotes il
vous faut dix kilos de marc de café est
qu'une fois que vous avez récolté ces
bleus roth
il vous reste encore 6 kg de substrat
est bon trouver une solution à des
déchets pour générer du déchet derrière
c'était pas vraiment dans l'esprit on
s'est dit tout simplement à quoi sert le
muséum dans la nature mais en fait il
sert à plein de choses
c'est notamment le connecteur entre le
monde du minéral et le monde du végétal
et donc on a travaillé que des gens qui
savent on a trahi l'inra avec
agroparistech qui nous ont dit mais
votre votre produit
il est génial donc ce qui était pour
nous potentiellement un déchet c'est en
fait un super fertilisants qui vous
permet de recréer des sols urbains
il ya plein de travaux sur la
dépollution des sols par le pleurote on
a on a un produit qu'on pourrait désirer
en tant que tel et donc vous voyez
progressivement se construire une grande
chaîne d'économie circulaire où on fait
tourner la roue comme ça plus on
collecte de marc de café plus on va
embaucher deux personnes en insertion et
plus on va produire de pleurotes plus on
va avoir de lien avec des chefs étoilés
locaux qui sont très intéressés plus on
va pouvoir améliorer et redonner toute
leur fonctionnalité aux sols urbains
locaux
ce qu'on a fait ensuite ses conseillers
comment dupliquer le système de la
manière la plus efficace possible parce
que ça c'est un site de production qui
prend la place mais ce qui a pas moyen
de miniaturiser ceci ce système et c'est
ce qu'on a fait on a fait une mini boîte
à sion pignon pour permettre à tout un
chacun de revaloriser votre marc de café
de chez vous qu'on va pas vous demander
de nous envoyer par la poste ce serait
un peu absurde écologiquement en
revanche vous fournir une petite boîte
qui va vous permettre de devenir
autonome en champignons et nos émetteurs
de marc de café il faut aussi valoriser
votre carte on peut valoriser tout un
tas de choses pour faire du marc de café
et des pleurotes sur marc de café vous
avez besoin de collecter des gros
volumes non collecte entre 5 à 10 tonnes
de marc de café par semaine donc parfois
vous en avez trop
et on s'est dit mais peut-être d'autres
applications possibles du marc de café
et donc on a créé un substrat à partir
de lombrics
on a donné à manger aux lombrics le marc
de café dont on n'avait pas besoin pour
de champignons et on a fait un substrat
hyper valoriser et donc c'est devenu un
centre de profit dans notre entreprise à
part entière que de valoriser cette
ressource par le lombric on avait un
autre problème c'est que quand vous
produisez du champignon vous produisez
beaucoup de co2 parce que le processus
de fermentation
j'espère qu'à pas de biologistes que
c'est pas du tout la fermentation génère
du co2 sauf que quand vous avez beaucoup
de co2 et bah c'est à peu près ce que
cherche tous les horticulteurs de france
et du monde pour faire pousser plus vite
des végétaux et donc on a lancé une
activité de micro pouces concrètement
ces petites barquettes de micropuces
elles sont au dessus de norak de
champignons et donc dans un même espace
on va cultiver des micropuces qui sont
des toutes petites pousses 40 fois plus
énergique et plein de vitamines et très
apprécié des chefs en même temps qu'on
va produire de champignons et comme
c'est par les mêmes réseaux commerciaux
comme ça c'est par les mêmes systèmes on
ne fait que améliorer le système et
résoudre un problème qu'on avait qui est
quand même on n'a pas envie de passer
nos journées à émettre du co2 en trop et
une fois qu'on a fait ça on peut pas
s'empêcher de se dire que cette boucle
va continuer à monter a monté à monter
donc on se brident régulièrement en
disant bon bah faut peut-être arrêter un
peu faut peut-être commencer à se
développer à faire ce qu'on a à se
développer mais ce que j'ai envie de
vous transmettre c'est que c'est une
mécanique qui se met et qui a grandi qui
a grandi on est de plus en plus
d'acteurs n'a de plus en plus
d'opérateurs qui viennent nous
accompagner à là dedans
en conclusion j'aimerais vous interroger
sur quelques points
ces points principaux c'est comment
trouver votre place dans votre propre
écosystème nous c'est ça notre obsession
on se focalise sur l'écosystème d'île de
france
mais en fait pourquoi on se poserait pas
tous la question dans nos vies comment
est nous mêmes acteurs d'un écosystème
dont je vais vous livrer une petite
méthode au conte à la première question
qu'on va se poser c'est de quelles
ressources abondamment disponibles on
peut se nourrir et cette ressource
elle peut prendre plein de formes ça
peut être une ressource économique ça
peut être une ressource spirituel ça
peut être déjà en détresse ça peut être
des gens qui ont trop d'argent et auquel
en valeur
ça peut avoir vraiment beaucoup de
formes le deuxième point et nous c'est
ce qui nous donne plaisir à nous lever
le matin c'est comment à partir de cette
ressource je peux en faire un truc
formidable qu'est ce que j'ai en moi
alors moi ce que j'ai en moi c'est mon
plaisir à toucher à plein de choses en
même temps à brasser plein de choses et
donc voyez on brasse là et donc c'est
cette question là haut le coeur du
plaisir de travailler il est aussi au
coeur de l'efficacité économique et la
troisième question qu'on se pose souvent
beaucoup moins c'est ce que je sais pas
valorisé moi même à qui je peux confier
dans des bonnes conditions pour que lui
même puisse bien le valoriser et ça ça
ouvre plein de perspectives
ça ouvre notamment des liens entre les
grandes entreprises et les start up
sound des liens entre les collectivités
et les particuliers
parce que il n'ya pas de honte à dire
qu'on est mauvais sur un point en
revanche il ya un grand gâchis à ne pas
prendre le temps d identifier les bonnes
personnes qui savent en faire quelque
chose de formidable et c'est comme ça
qu'on crée des grands écosystèmes
mon dernier message ma dernière question
qui est le truc qui nous anime et qui à
mon avis fera qu'on arrivera à peu près
à vivre ans en 2030
c'est de savoir si on va être assez
intelligent mais surtout assez humain
pour réussir à changer nos vies en
fonction de ce que la nature à nous
apporter
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]